where like
three slush margaritas down is starting
to beat my ass
so i'm like trying to take it slow i'm
eating hell of the [ __ ] fish i flip
it over that's how much of the fish i'm
eating
yeah and he looked at me he said
uh yeah i'm with this [ __ ] right now
i'm like what cause he been on facetime
this whole time i just been entertaining
the hoes
and he turned the phone and he put me on
facetime is
his him e40 ice cube and snoop dogg
and then he just take his airpods out
hand it to me and i don't know nothing
about what they've been talking about or
nothing and then and 40 going hard
talking about what's up he's showing me
love
snoop instantly was like what's up
netflix
ice cube ice cube is like who is this
guy hella [ __ ]
menacing but he was showing me love at
the same time but he was so sick he was
literally like this
he was like yeah no short was telling us
no i see i see i i never heard of you
but i'm finna check you out
cause snoop said you creative and i was
like
oh no you know i'll be i'll be making
content [ __ ]
mister you gotta be in the next friday
i heard chris tucker doesn't want to be
in it he acted as [ __ ] and did snoop
and short was like man you should direct
the whole video i was like if y'all give
me a song to do it i'll do it
for sure do it for free yeah i'll do it
please let me do it
but um that was probably my my last star
struck moment for sure
oh yeah that face time's crazy it was
tight too because it was really
christening me like nah
if short it's giving you the okay snoop
already did it
40 partially did it now all right
cube's on board we [ __ ] with you